[Musique]
c'est cool dans le studio
j'avais envie de te présenter votre des
spectateurs parce que je trouve que tu
fais le mélange parfait entre le fond et
la forme des images qui attire
l'attention par leur beauté mais aussi
qu'il faut réfléchir
merci ma wii du moins j'espère ça fait
plaisir qu'il prenne comme ça miss mi
aime choquer mais choqué pour provoquer
la réflexion pour moi l'art est une
intention et c'est pour ça que les
choses qui pourraient paraître
absolument être rien mais c'est une
pièce d'à choses qui sont
extraordinaires mais l'intention n'a pas
été une véritable attention artistique
est authentique et du coup se parlant à
ses oeuvres mettent souvent celle des
corps de femmes et des critiques acerbes
de notre société
elle a longtemps résisté avant d'exposer
dans les galeries de parts de sacrifier
son authenticité
mais lorsqu'elles sont ils pas le succès
a été instantané
parmi ses clients célèbres madonna ou le
guitariste dave navarro
qu'est-ce que ses thèmes de prédilection
et que je parle beaucoup de féminisme
non mon travail parce que je parle
beaucoup de ma de ma relation à la
société c'est la réappropriation tout
simplement parce que finalement le corps
et la sexualité de la femme dans
énormément de culture lui a été volé
littéralement
et c'est complètement taré quand y pense
on nous a volé notre propre corps et
notre propre sexualité qui est qui et
qui la source pour moins de notre
pouvoir et de notre épanouissement de
travailler dans le monde de la pub de
lui l'occasion de voir justement cette
utilisation du quart de la fin pour
ordre des choses
en tout avec le corps de la femme cécile
c'est un truc incroyable mais ça ça veut
bien dire qui a un réel pouvoir là
derrière avec ses oeuvres elle souhaite
susciter la réflexion et ultime en faire
changer les choses
c'est l'opportunité extraordinaire que
pour l'homme
de se redéfinir comme lui il veut aussi
parce qu'au final le patriarcat et la
presse tout le monde il ya des gens qui
comme n'importe quel système de pouvoir
comparer envie de lâcher ce pouvoir
parce que ça les arrange parce qu'ils
sont au dessus puis surtout parce qu'ils
sont perdus quand on essaie de redéfinir
les choses et bah tant pis quoi parce
que c'est fini quoi les semis une
artiste qui me faut définitivement pas
moqué ici nabi alexandre chartier à 2
canada montréal
[Musique]